so tell me what's on your mind
well it just hurts you know when you're
poor all you want to be is not
poor in Louisiana somehow feels extra
poor because I'm not being poured next
to a swamp that makes you go oh I might
not make it out of this okay
there's no polite way to say so cross me
on the sidewalk there was a crackhead
that was dancing right
but he wasn't dancing to any music just
to the rhythm of the cracks
I got just famous enough that's like I
have big or something like I gotta be
very careful when I move through these
streets
kill millions of people but somehow
everyone that I owe money lived
there's a means to process it's a way to
Exhale hurt some people cry some people
scream and I laugh
[Applause]
[Music]